Vista, by virtue of its simplicity, by making
one of the problems go away, namely, the power
failure, the implementation is very simple. 700 lines of
code in Vista as opposed to more than 10,000
k lines of code in the original LRVM implementation.
Why? Because there are no redo logs. All the
changes that we're making to virtual memory for persistent
data structure directly get in to the data segments.
So no redo logs. Correspondingly, there is no truncation
code, and check pointing and recovery code is significantly
simplified, and there is no group commit optimizations. The
upshot of all of these simplifications that comes from
one simple trick and that is to make a
portion of the DRam persistent. And implement the file
cache with that persistent portion of DRAM can get
rid of redo logs and get rid of truncation
code and Vista has the simplicity of
LRVM but it is also performance efficient. I
encourage you to browse through the performance
results that are reported in the paper on
Rio Vista which I have assigned for
your reading. To see how Vista performs compared
to LRVM. In particular, Vista performs three
orders of magnitude better than the original LRVM
because of the simplicity and the fact that there is no disk IO. That
is the biggest improvement in making Vista perform really well compared to LRVM.